20s that's where you would expect a 2800
player to be that means on average per
move he'll lose 0.2 compared to the top
computer suggestions but that's still
very good that's very accurate and Eric
meanwhile still good 43 but not in the
same accuracy level as Magnus uh okay
the game has started it's an Italian
opening but we will talk about some of
these stats as we go along especially
end games
87. how incredible is that number
meaning he wins 80 percent of the games
that goes into the end game that's crazy
or at least his accuracy I yeah I mean
that's I mean he's
clearly one of the best end game players
of all time he's got uh endgames is a is
a really interesting error of of Chess
which I'm definitely uh not uh feeling
most comfortable in but
um a lot of it's just to do with peace
placement intuition good calculation and
Magnus got all of those of course and
well is it about in this game then
Ferrari to keep the Queens on never
enter the end game with Magnus it looks
that way I think that's just good advice
for anyone in general Lawrence I'll get
you there I'll get you my chessboard
course with Magnus
it's funny I went out into the foyer and
I saw it it was being played on the big
screen
um but what a curious opening by Magnus
to go for this this is what I used to
play when I was 12 years old uh oh yeah
it's it's not the most popular opening
necessarily like you say after kind of
Club level yeah especially at Grand
Master Level you very rarely see this
nowadays but um okay it's level material
white the first to Castle black has the
bishop pair slightly fractured Pawn
structure isn't this a specialty of uh
gawaine Jones yes English Grandmaster
and what is the opening
Scotch Gambit never heard of yeah so
it's a it's kind of a mix between the
Italian game and the scotch game and you
kind of throw them together and you get
this yeah which is a bit of a mess and
normally it gets really wild with both
sides throwing pawns forward towards you
towards each other
um there are some strategic aspects
black support structure not ideal but
yeah the bishop power has fantastic
potential it's normally got quite a good
reputation for black this opening ah at
least historically and uh known as a bit
of a tricky one for white yeah and just
checking the database I can just see
that the highest rated player who's
played this with the white pieces is
Magnus Carlson himself against Liam
otherwise
otherwise it's just a row or just a
whole line of Dwayne Jones's games
yeah he's done quite well with it I have
to say impressive stats that's the thing
if you know an opening really well even
if objectively it's maybe not the best
opening then you'll get good results if
you know it better than your opponent
and this one
yeah it's out of fashion and maybe
that's just a good
uh kind of a good piece of advice to
follow if an opening is out of fashion
you can reinvent it you can pick it up
your opponent might not be familiar with
what to do
well is this a sign Magnus that's
experimenting maybe working on openings
right now maybe isn't training mode been
in and working on some new stuff yeah
yeah I mean Magnus is busy man but he's
always working on chess he's always
studying always kind of craving these
new ideas
or at least old forgotten ideas uh where
he does kind of pick them up and add his
own touch
I mean this bishop moved very popular
I'm surprised to see Magnus pause
it's an interesting because I believe it
or not I've played I've played this a
lot myself as well in fact I had a game
in this line against one of the
participants of this event
ah you had white I had white and it was
the world under 14 championships or
under 16 Champions nice so before you
were born Kaya a nice memory
it wasn't a nice memory actually because
I had a great position and he was
already 2500 I was only like 22.50 at
the time and I had a fantastic position
and I blew it
um so the memory wasn't that nice
because it was like oh I'm beating I'm
beating my Majora before I'm better and
yet here he was deciding whether to push
F3 and kick the Knight immediately or
Play Bishop B3 and there are some small
nuances for example in this position
here
if I remember them correctly the move
Queen E7 now exists and now if you kick
the Knight with F3 you've got this
surprising move Knight to D6 because the
uh
because the bishop on E3 is hanging
however Eric goes the the standard way
with Bishop B6 and now I expect Magnus
to kick with F3 he'll move the Knight to
G5 and then he'll probably kick the
Knight again with F4
gaining some time and
yeah I had this position a lot in my
life yeah come in challenge the night
challenge the Knights of the square as
well I think yeah yeah and it's all
about like whether you know it's all
about restraining Pawns in a way you
know black will try to advance the
double pawns they have on the C line and
white will try to control those pawns
and on the flip side white will actually
try to push their pawns and try to use
the F Pawn as a bulldozer I just open
lines against the black king So
intriguing race yeah very rich position
uh dynamically strategically it's just
really really hard to handle for both
sides and
for me it's it's a bit worrying to see
that Eric is pausing at this moment it's
something that for sure he studied at
some point maybe when he was 12 years
old as you mentioned that Lawrence but
um if the world Champion's playing this
against you and it's so direct it's so
unbalanced you really need to know what
you're doing
um so okay white we mentioned could push
forward I'm not sure you need to rush I
think there's a few other moves in this
position I vaguely remember this one
being uh being a move as well just
pushing the queen forward
um but yeah it's been years since I
studied this one too uh it's it's hard
to retrieve for all these memories as
Ivanka said uh galwayne still played
this very much when he was over 2600
with with some good results did some
work on this but as far as I understand
if you really really really know what
you're doing here with black
you can get a really good position
because the two bishops come alive
at some point and they can terrorize so
I'm very curious to see if Magnus does
play something new here I'm very curious
because it does mean that he might have
done some more it doesn't look like it
though by his body language feels as
though he's kind of just uh going move
by move here almost yeah it's strange
that both players are thinking because
okay it's a rare line or an older line
that we mentioned but okay pushing a
pawn forward now but it's the type of
line where you need to kind of know what
you're doing long term black is doing
very well with those Bishops short-term
white maybe uh the favorite and okay the
evaluation bar doesn't like magnus's
move it feels like he's freestyling
actually with this last one Ivanka has
this been played before it has been
played before
um the latest one was gavrolescu in
2022. it's called Romanian player yeah
and then Misa Pap in 2008 was also the
next highest rated player but you're
right David it's not the most popular
choice and white is just simply saying I
want to restrain those pawns that black
has on the C line I want to control the
advance and then he's gonna get on with
his plan or for pushing forward the F1
there it comes I was beginning to
question my life it's existence if that
pawn wasn't going to get pushed yeah so
finally kicking away this night we
expect the Knight to plonk itself back
into the center
um I guess you could maybe make an
argument for dropping back
this would just invite white Ford so yep
the Knight does indeed recentralize and
now Magnus tries to trade off Black's
best piece it's heating up this game I
think from its opening it's much more
promising than the last uh last game we
followed yeah definitely feels uh
entertaining and balanced everything we
could hope for two players that well
know each other quite well recently
played on the same team in the European
Club Championship for the Norwegian team
offers Bill and are they also good
friends these two like kind of had the
impression during the also Esports cup
when Eric was in Oslo that these two
they had a good chemistry yeah
Eric with his Norwegian sounding name
yeah I guess he's got I mean my uncle's
name is Eric Hansen is it yeah oh wow
it's uh he's got a Norwegian sounding
name and I guess that strengthens his
bond to I know he's very good friends
with Aryan tari and one of magnus's
of teammates annoy as well so but I
wanted to say one thing about events
such as the European Club championships
because I just actually played in that
myself and it's a very unifying event
you know you have dinner with your team
you analyze with your team you have
breakfast you play the games alongside
and it just feels like you're part of a
group of friends I mean it's so rare
yeah not to get on with your teammates
team events must be so much fun yeah it
is it's a lot of fun and it's somehow
just a lot more relaxed than you would
get and say in the Olympiad where it
just feels like it's high pressure and
there's a lot of things at stake the
European Club I cup I mean it just felt
like five friends in the case of the
women that's nice just hanging out yeah
and in the open section you know what I
did see the office bill they were
hanging out all the time yeah I mean
they they walked to the venue together
they also left the venue together and
there was I think they were sharing the
same location as well venue
that's very nice and actually so the
Czech team that won the open section we
have several players in this tournament
that won the European Club cup Nils
grendelius was in that team David Anton
and uh did it was it was also there he
had a tremendous score six out of seven
six out of six and then he lost his
final game and then of course Hare
Krishna he also did very well on board
one yeah so yeah fun friends yeah
um being busy the players in the game
chess rapid these two busy making moves
we have a couple more on the board yeah
we have a couple more white tonight has
been kicked away from the center so as
Ivanka was advocating both sides pushing
pawns blacks uh C Pawn pushing the White
Knight I don't really like the squares
landed on but maybe it was necessary and
Eric's dilemma is what to do with his
own night does he trade off
you try and maintain it there it's not
that easy to do so
Magnus meanwhile laughing to himself or
he was at least a moment ago something
we've seen But back to the poker face
and what would you guys be thinking here
and Lawrence I guess with your
experience uh albeit a while ago yeah so
in general as black here what what you
really want to do is you want to trade
this Knight off the ball because you
can't really allow Knight takes E4 your
your pawns uh
get shattered in your Bishop on B6 could
be logged out of the game forever so
what you tend to do is you take on D2
Queen takes D2 and then the bishop
normally comes to either C6 or B5 let's
put it on C6 looking for a greener
pastures along the long diagonal but
what Eric is thinking about I'm pretty
sure is what to do if Magnus just goes
all in here with F5 and uh you know F6
is coming and suddenly your king might
be in some Court some kind of mating net
now I'm not sure if this works I'm not
sure what the the exact move is here for
black but it looks scary optically it
looks
this is for sure why Eric is taking a
moment
um if you don't do that then what are
you supposed to do because if you trade
nights let's say Knight takes D2 Queen
takes D2
you now have this D5 Pawn hanging and
you can play a move like Bishop F5 but
that runs into Knight G3 I don't like
that gaining tons of time you can't put
the bishop on E6 it runs into Pawn to F5
so what are you actually supposed to do
play a move like C6 but that's a very
tough move to play because now for
example white can go all positional and
play B4 for example it might be an
interesting move try and get a grip over
those dark squares or a bind as it's
called in chess lingo suddenly all of
those squares in the middle white can
occupy with his pieces and now Magnus
would really be an as element if these
dark Square bishops come off the board
Knight versus Bishop middle game oof
that's what he's he would dream of this
position he had it uh he'd he'd uh he'd
sell that cabin in Sweden if he could if
he could get that position every game
and and now we're gonna see it so let's
see what Eric does here and he's going
to take a pause
I'm there what do you think David do you
think he's gonna play C6 I can't see it
I agree with you it's a really critical
moment right now the evaluation bar
isn't bothered at all that's probably
because in one of these variations for
example if the bishop moves uh probably
because this attack for white isn't
actually as dangerous as it looks but
like you say for a human
and then that's the key Point here for a
human in a rapid game where you don't
have time to calculate it looks so scary
whoops sorry to allow this Pawn stepping
forward and he actually plays your move
um your first instinct so The Bishop's
potentially on a good diagonal if things
open up but this one is blocked in and
your king is kind of left to its own
devices
Ivanka
this is
what sort of position
would you go F5 here of course yeah I
can no doubt one thousand percent one
thousand percent look at that here we go
there we go and uh we have it on the
board you know I mean it's every
person's dream right I mean I don't care
what the computer says computers could
say like black is winning but I'd be
very happy yeah
or I mean just look at that King it's
got zero Defenders around it it's got
two pawns rushing towards it the bishop
is coming to this Square maybe even to
sacrifice itself to open things up The
Rook could potentially be coming at some
point to swing over
um yeah if we had Simon William sitting
here still he would be
salivatingly drooling at the thought of
this uh position and uh Eric just has to
do something urgently
um I'm not sure what maybe you could
block the advance of this Pawn by
pushing your own Pawn forward but you do
weaken this Square
um firstly the pawn could just push and
past uh passport on there or at some
point later then I could start jumping
in if you don't push that pawn forward
what else do you do I don't really see
any sacrifices working okay he does play
it maybe he needed to oh now things get
very exciting because
all kinds of things are in the air here
now for example
um
if white takes this Pawn or white leaves
it uh what are you thinking look my my
first instinct was to leave the pool
because I didn't want to trade and
activate the dark Square Bishop the
black has
but then again
it's tempting I do like the move though
I do like the move because it's what
black needs to do actually Eric is
activating that was why he put the
bishop on Z6 to open that long diagonal
and now for example just a sample line
if you play for example Bishop G5 here
just moving away you gain an important
template because you can play Queen to
D5
and you're threatening mate all of a
sudden so I do like this move and Magnus
has decided to take and now actually
taking back is not automatic whatsoever
yeah I mean you you could take back
um what else would you be considering
right now Lawrence I think this queen
move you would love to play it but
unfortunately white can uh actually I'm
not sure whether this way maybe the
other way the other way with the Knight
you can hit the queen and you can defend
this Pawn at the same time
um not quite working for you out there
so
um okay let's look at the obvious one at
least uh Pawn takes Pawn
um now if you take with the bishop now
you're pinned on the D file and you're
pinned on this diagonal which isn't
ideal so I guess Magnus would want to
recapture with the Knight he would be a
pawn up temporarily
it's not just any point as well it's one
of these two
still tricky the evaluation Bar says
complete zeros not impressed at all but
feels like there might be a tactic here
it feels very close to being something
for black at least white has
overextended potentially the king is not
the Knight is pinned David because Queen
takes D2 so if I can I play a simple
move like Queen D5 here yeah just to
show your point uh Knight takes Bishop
looks like it solves issues but after
quintix Queen White can't recapture
um due to a pin on this diagonal so yeah
maybe you're right actually maybe that's
the clever finesse
again it's not entirely clear what the
thread is maybe oh Queen takes E5 might
exist because E3 is hanging yeah maybe
taking the spawn maybe just swinging The
Rook I don't have more pressure that's
the real threat just activating those
Rooks yeah okay he's going for it I
think we will see this position on the
board and
um if Eric puts his Queen in Center he
has just done as you mentioned there as
He suggests Lawrence
yeah he is not wired up to this
commentary
it's just playing good moves he's
logical moves as well yeah it's cost him
a lot of time that's the one downfall
for Eric he's got a good position
healthy position but six minutes but uh
now is the time for white to regroup and
start looking after The King and I like
magnus's last move I was also maybe
considering moving The Rook up one
square as well just to kind of over
protect the queen
but uh the pawn on E5 still can't be
taken because it'd be oh you can and it
has been taken it has been taken okay
the idea is that the bishop Falls but if
the bishop falls to the black queen can
take the white Bishop which was hanging
and we'd be in an end game Magnus loves
those end games that we've seen but
um the question is in this position is
White's King good in the corner no the
black Bishop's pretty decent white
tonight also very good but uh is it
enough to win
not easy not easy and if Magnus doesn't
go for this if he doesn't go for the end
game what's he doing uh he risks being
worse if he leaves the two black bishops
on the board he does take it
and we're gonna head straight into this
end game okay
well now we can take a breath and uh
Eric won't lose on time he's uh still
got some work to do though especially
this white knight which controls two
squares the black Brooks want to use
black wants to use this Square black
maybe wants to use this square but both
are covered by this Knight so this
Knight is a real thorn in his side
who do you prefer and why tricky one um
very very tricky one
I feel that uh white is still better
despite all the exchanges that's
happened I mean white will have access
to the open lines as you've highlighted
also there's that possibility of pushing
the F Pawn One Square Four to F6 and
just locking out the black king
obviously that's a double-edged sword
you know it could be a very weak Pawn
you have there but in the meantime
black has to play a few accurate moves
and it's not easy how he's going to
activate the Rooks yeah maybe we can
pull up those interest stats again just
to see the end games uh Magnus what was
it 87 or something it was incredible and
games that he'd won on the tour this
season and Rapid chess
Eric I've always always thought of him
as quite a good end game player or quite
decent and there we go 87 from like this
61 for Eric's still good yeah
it's uh it looks clear there's a
favorite and uh we don't need to look at
the other steps necessarily for this
game but interesting that uh Eric keeps
up in most of the other categories
actually Advantage capitalization both
of them very good there decisiveness
Eric playing many decisive games
and uh resourcefulness Eric pretty
resourceful even if things go wrong 30
now but okay end game it's just about
that one
and uh what I like about these
at least it does give you a clear way to
improve your chess okay it tells you you
know if Magnus is 87 and you're 67 you
know if you want to be the same level as
Magnus get your end game starts to be
better so uh I like it is that something
the chess players are working more and
more on the end game
hard to say I I would say no actually
um so much emphasis on opening Theory
nowadays
so much you can actually win games out
of the opening right with old Theory and
you can guarantee you'll get certain
positions in the opening uh so end games
it's kind of General you'll never get
the same end game twice or very rarely
but have you studied any games Lawrence
is that something that uh has
contributed to your
your success
not enough let's put it like that and
gives us the part we always want to
study always it's the part we pretend we
study but it's actually hard to knuckle
down and say okay I'm gonna look at Rook
end games today yeah yeah and it's
it's um yeah it's it's an entirely
different Universe actually there are
some players that just dedicate their
lives right I mean if you there are some
Grandma Carson Miller for example the
famous Grandma Sarah of Hamburg
an in-game freak in in a good sense
right in you know he just does end games
end games end games
um
it's it's it's tough It's it's almost a
different game somehow but uh Magnus
playing I've been looking at this and
I've been trying to work out what kind
of setup I would play and he puts the
bishop on C5 and he wants to put the
bishop on D6 and just use that Bishop as
a bit of a uh what I oh if you can
imagine a wine bottle cork
so when you've had a glass of wine you
put the cork back in that's what that
Bishop would do on D6
work with
the one you can put those rubber cords
back in yeah yeah yeah
um that's that's how I view but actually
Eric isn't quite in time to
to get the configuration he wants now
the cork if you put it back uh in the
bottle then actually drop this point or
does he or can you oh maybe maybe you
can do it anyway because you need to
drink the whole bottle tonight yeah
maybe it's too much Fizz in the position
because now if you take this Pawn you do
get uh you do get the black Rook active
hitting the Knight and hitting the pawn
behind it and if you take with the
knight in this position instead then a
little bit loose this Knight is
hanging by a thread these pawns still
vulnerable to the black Rooks but maybe
it's working just about for Magnus Eric
doesn't really want to give up a pawn
that's a very concrete line right
so it does look shaky for white but it
does look like white surviving and a
pawn is a pawn yeah it's a big question
for Eric can he plug the holes can he
put that cork back in or does he have to
play this move in which case he's lost
time I think he's I think he should just
give up the pawn I mean get active yeah
I mean this is very much if you Retreat
the bishop to the B6 Square I mean you
allow the other white Rook sitting on F1
to park itself on the open E Line and
then the other rope is coming to Bay
Brooks are going to come to the seventh
row and I don't know this is like misery
Central
well I always thought that black could
just shift over the effort to E8 put the
King on f8 and claim no harm done oh
yeah try and trade all the Rooks off
yeah all the Rooks come off Black's
Bishop okay with pawns on both sides of
the board it's doing an okay job he's
doing fine yeah potentially potentially
there are still some interesting issues
there but okay he goes he does go for it
yeah cook is back in the bottle
it's party tonight it's coming at a high
price there uh will Magnus grab this guy
I think you've got to because if you
allow black now just to play A4 on the
next move Rook fe8 King to f8 and
consolidate
zero-ish in fact you start to prefer
black because there's a bit of pressure
so he's he's going active Ivanka yeah he
had to do I think he had to do this
and well Magnus is uh pushing his bones
on the queen side and uh at least the
Rooks got active it has got active but
uh
the White Knight just comes back and is
also acting like the cork you mentioned
just uh keeping all those pawns
protected Knight defends everything
defends the spawn okay also it was this
cork was hitting this Cork and uh one of
them had to give away I really didn't
like Eric's last move I actually played
it so quickly
um because actually it's not necessarily
a huge threat to capture this bishop
um for example if black
okay they're a more productive moves but
um here if black can somehow uh get one
of these pawns off the board it should
just be a draw even if white ends up
pulling up in a pure Rook end game Rook
end games have such a Jewish tendency
but he ran away with his Bishop maybe
his ideas to just come and attack this
Pawn
but why didn't you like it Lawrence
I'm not sure exactly I mean of course it
allows Rook B7 uh immediately
they
uh and if Bishop F6 B3 and Rook D2 also
exists of course yeah okay you can bully
your opponent now you're a pawn up uh
Rook drops back actually yeah it feels
like Magnus is consolidating he's
regrouped holding everything together
and I wish now you know we have that
Ding after every move that it was uh the
cork out of the bottle sound
with every move
I'll get tiring
what happens because you associate when
the court comes out the bottle you
associate with good times right imagine
you've got a miserable position it's
like congratulations congratulations
now this is miserable now for for Eric
and uh well he's doing some active
thinking of pushing the H Pawn
that's that's a plan but the problem is
is that his Rooks although active they
don't actually have any purpose I mean
black Rook on the A-line has to guard
against the advance of the white apron
so
um and uh well Magnus is coming forward
yeah it's so instructive what Magnus has
done as well with the white king the
white King was on the first rank it was
a terrible piece but now it's on a
really nice Square on a light Square
Magnus is going for that light Square
strategy right just putting everything
on the opposite color from the
opponent's Bishop
uh I was also on the lights going out
stopping the Black Brook from attacking
those horns in the third rank yeah it's
just slow and steady
um what is Eric's plan look at Eric's
body language as well just kind of
exhaling we've all been there right when
we know we're struggling we just don't
have a plan and
it's kind of a double whammy when your
opponent is the greatest end game player
of all time
it's like uh the tortoise and the hair
right this is tortoise just slow and
steady wins the race I must remember it
it's like a snail just one square
forward and move later another square
and uh The Rook moves to the edge of the
board and well this is very exciting
position we see Magnus doing magnus's
things and uh whilst Eric is thinking
sorry Magnus is thinking just like to
share with you a few selfies uh first
one comes from jmr18 who says that
they're watching us from the Beer Garden
in rainy Germany oh well still very cool
yeah Garden so cheers to you I'm gonna
salute you with my tea
and the night Retreats again over
protecting all the pawns I love this
type of chess I mean this is the worst
possible thing you could ever wish for
against Magnus this is just you've got
no counter play your dynamism doesn't
exist you are just slowly getting
strangled
and Eric knows this yeah Eric is fully
aware of what's going on it's yes you
sounded like that Eeyore just then
from Winnie the Pooh Winnie the Pooh oh
no is that what he said
um
yeah
um sorry no no no it's I take it he was
he was cuddly and nice wasn't he or I'll
take it yeah
um no this is horrible yeah Knight G4 is
a great move yeah the evaluation bar
showed up I was wondering whether white
could have been gradient has gone to
grab a second Pawn White's Rook on the C
file
I could have grabbed that isolated Pawn
on C7 and Magnus yeah just keeping
control and you could just see at that
sigh from Eric
he just knows it's over Magnus is in his
elements
yeah for any chess player this is uh
suffering but
actually when this is your opponent and
okay the bishop moving
makes some sense but now he gets greedy
and I think he's got enough control
Magnus that he can get away with this
and he checks on the second rank will be
blocked by White's F Rook
um The Rook is sitting there near the
white king which we'll see most likely
think the king wants to go on any
Journeys into the corner just feels
unnecessary so block the check yeah
he's lined it up so beautifully I mean
there's no tactics whatsoever in Eric's
favor and
he moves his Rook tactics against the
black king
do you see what's happening yeah we're
gonna see actually Magnus go on the
attack uh the black king when it moves
to this okay is Eric gonna resign
because if you block this check it's
pretty much the same as resigning right
um you can drop back with the black Rook
or the black Bishop but if the King goes
to the edge of the board the White
Knight is going to jump into the center
and start going for the black king
okay we'll see this on the board
it's the white knight will jump to the
middle attack the rook and also threaten
the F7 Pawn and the black king is in a
mating net yeah I think we're going to
see just body language wise Eric is
about to resign any moment
and there we go the black Christmas
attack the black porn was attacked
nothing to be done yeah it's a win for
Magnus Carlsen striking back after
losing in the first round now three
points in this uh second game against
Eric Hansen it was a great game by the
world number one 41 moves he took it
into the end game and of course won it
in the end game